my name is Daisy I'm with shields were
here for your protection they built a
team to defend the world what is
happening to me against the very ones
they fight to save we call ourselves in
humans but now face a threat I'm not
scared
you should be that is beyond
hey youtubers it's Charlie so new agents
of shield trailer for season 3 teasing
some of the stuff that's gonna be
happening in the first episode but you
know just in general
showing off lash as the new big bad for
at least the first half of the season
what the show's doing this year is a
version of secret warriors from the
comics from that storyline blended with
the new Inhumans run before Secret Wars
if you've never met lash before he just
debuted last year he's a relatively new
character he came out of the
terrigenesis storyline where Inhumans
started popping up everywhere
blackbolt set off a Terrigen bomb in
humans started popping up everywhere so
they're doing a version of that on the
TV show right now but Coulson's team
itself is gonna be patterned on secret
warriors from the comics which is
something from the scroll invasion some
of you guys might remember that that all
happened in the wake of civil war in the
comics Civil War destabilized the world
and it set the stage for a scroll
invasion and no I don't think that
they're gonna do Scrolls in the movies
but it is a nice coincidence that
they're doing Captain America Civil War
next spring it just makes it for a
really awesome crossover with agents of
shield I'll talk about that a little bit
more at the end of the video let's talk
a little bit more about what's going on
with the TV characters I don't know for
sure but I think that Skye might start
going as Daisy a lot more her inner
circle of friends might start calling
her Daisy more and more I mean like
she'll always be Skye to her closest
friends but she's a lot more comfortable
with her identity as Daisy Johnson so
she might start thinking of herself as
Daisy more and more they teased a little
bit of tension between Lincoln and Mack
if you remember Mack hates all Inhumans
and Lincoln is one of the new inhuman
defectors that defected to Team Coulson
he seems like he's going all tough-guy
in the trailer but he really is a good
character and Simmons I know everybody
is still wondering about Simmons stuck
in that obelisk last year whenever she
got sucked in I was pretty sure that she
would come back like they weren't
killing her off the show it was just
them pending the season on a huge jump
scare but when she comes back is she
going to be changed we don't know a lot
about the obelisk itself but it doesn't
look like it imbues people with inhuman
powers it's meant to fight Inhumans and
the actress herself says that she feels
like she's somewhere inside there so
might just have multiple properties but
I don't think that she would have gotten
sucked in if she didn't have inhuman DNA
in her it would be pretty cool to see
her get some powers but I think most of
the people that we see getting powers in
season 3 will be the juicers that eat
those fish oil pills and they kind of
tease one
the new ones in the trailer the only
thing we know about him is that his name
is Joey there are gonna be a couple
other teams that know they're not doing
hammer but they are doing a government
based team that's hunting down in humans
they're called like the advanced threat
containment unit and there are a couple
characters like Constance Zimmer that
will be working with them they're gonna
have the same relationship the Captain
America and Iron Man have an in civil
war like the government won't be bad but
they will be the antagonist to Coulson's
team Coulson's team will always be the
main protagonists lash will be the crazy
murdery stabby villain Ward will also be
a villain and I'll be really interested
to see if there's like somebody that
lash is working for that we meet in the
second half of the season that award
ends up working with two in the world of
agents of shield like in this TV world
Ward is the closest thing we have to a
Loki character just a little bit crazy
with constantly shifting allegiances
Brett Dalton is awesome but he's no Tom
Hiddleston but he will be having a lot
of fun this season
I feel like evil Ward is so much more
fun than season 1 Ward you guys can let
me know though if we know that lash is
gonna be like like the stabby villain
for the first half of the season at
least do you think that he is actually
working for another inhuman like another
faction of Inhumans part of the reason
why he's so crazy in the comics is is
because he feels like terrigenesis is
something special only a select few are
supposed to be able to take in the
Terrigen mists so when everybody gets to
do it it kind of pisses him off he goes
on this crazy holy mission to eliminate
all these brand new Inhumans in the
comics they call them new humans as in
like nu humans but as part of that new
Inhumans arc I mean I mean before secret
Ward's went down
people like lineage here started to
emerge lineage is just one of the
leaders of a evil Inhumans group
typically when we think of the Inhumans
we think of the traditional royal family
like Black Bolt Medusa there are bad
groups of Inhumans that have risen up
the interesting thing in the comics
though is that lineage actually had a
son named Joey
so that might behoove is Joey characters
we see in this trailer so don't be
surprised if flash is taking orders from
another evil inhuman but it feels like
what they've been suggesting is is that
lash is going to be the main villain for
the first half of the season at least
just remember that a lot of times
they'll take like the framework of a lot
of comic book arcs and they'll change
them to fit with the characters that
they already have like the secret
warriors from the comics that's not
going to be the
backstory line that they have on the TV
show we might see some of the other
Inhumans that we meet during Lash's arc
in the comics but I mean we'll have to
see it can be kind of expensive to do
inhuman powers so they're gonna try to
be pretty economic with like the the
level of craziness that they do usually
they say the really big powers like
whether you have tons of special effects
for premieres midseason finales and
season finales
what about crossover with Captain
America Civil War and a lot of people
are asking if characters with
superpowers will go to the movies
normally I would say Coulson would
totally do a movie crossover I mean the
The Avengers age of Ultron crossover was
kind of lame this year but the problem
is is that Marvel Studios now is
reporting to a different group than
Marvel television like they're not all
under the same banner anymore so it
might be a little bit harder for them to
crossover well hot would have to wait
and see but I'm not expecting or at
least I'd be I'd be really surprised if
Chloe Bennett showed up in a cameo in
Captain America Civil War I think it's
more likely that we'll see Captain
America Civil War people come on agents
of shield but in case you guys haven't
seen it there's a bunch of other
trailers that have been dropping the
last couple of days so I'll put some
extra links in the description we got an
arrow season 4 trailer a flash season 2
trailer spy coming next week and we've
got a bunch of Doctor Who footage there
are a couple other shows that are
starting in the next two weeks or so so
just keep your eyes peeled I will be
doing heroes videos and I'll be doing
Doctor Who those will be the next two
shows to come back but I don't think
that they come back for like another two
weeks we will probably get a bunch more
footage from agents of shield though
whenever that comes I'll totally do more
trailer breakdowns so be sure to
subscribe to get that stuff if there are
any characters from the comics you guys
want me to do bonus videos for just let
me know in the comments if you guys
didn't see my video explaining like
what's going on with the drama at
Captain America Civil War Marvel you can
click here to learn all about that and
you can click here for that arrow season
4 trailer if you haven't seen it yet
thank you so much for watching everybody
let's high five I'll see you guys
tonight
you